les costumes de dark vador de luke
skywalker les fans étaient au rendez
vous ce mercredi 13 décembre pour la
sortie de star wars 8 dans ce cinéma de
saint quentin en yvelines
les amoureux de la saga n'ont pas hésité
à venir dès la première séance de la
journée à 9 heures 45 aujourd'hui très
important j'ai toujours essayé de
regarder les stars aux dernières sorties
et puis voilà c'est une expansion vers
au cinéma on a envie de connaître la
suite avait deux ans qu'on attend une
phrase de l'udc donc c'est important
d'être là aujourd'hui pour garder tout
ça on en profite parce que comme ça ça
évite à près de se faire spoiler par les
amis qui ont eu l'occasion d'y aller
avant donc comme ça c'est moi qui veux
pouvoir les spoilers dont une grosse
pensée à ceux qui travaillent au total
le multiplexe devrait attirer entre 4500
et 5000 personnes sur cette première
journée
on est pour l'instant sur les mêmes
tendances qui a deux ans on se
engouement dès ce matin dès les deux
premières séances confessera elles sont
quasiment plein donc c'est un véritable
engouement pour star wars
après plus de 2h30 plongé dans une
galaxie lointaine retour sur terre pour
un premier verdict franchement mille
fois meilleur que le précédent
excitant l'action était là
il y avait les retournements aussi il ya
de l'action iliad humour ya pas mal du
bon je m'attendais pas à autant d'humour
c'est bien c'est pas non plus trop fort
c'est chaud les derniers jedi devrait
être en exploitation entre deux et trois
mois dans ce cinéma saint quentinois
en france plus de 10 5 millions de
personnes s'étaient rendues au cinéma
pour voir l'épisode 7
il est temps
on peut lire
donc dsk
actuellement au cinéma